[Applause]
[Music]
we only have a few episodes of new
releases left this year but that doesn't
mean we're out of games to play and if
you're traveling over the coming weeks
good news almost all of this week's
games can be played anywhere I mean I
guess you could technically set up a
virtual reality rig inside your car but
that just doesn't seem safe so it's
probably best just to play monster of
the deep Final Fantasy 15 at home on
your PSP our this spin-off of last
year's RPG II turns noctis's hobby into
a full-fledged VR experience letting you
cast in a bunch of different spots and
reel in all sorts of creatures it's the
first VR title Square Enix has ever
published and you can catch it yourself
on Tuesday November 21st we've also got
some early gameplay you can check out if
you want to see how this fishing game
handles boss battles you can catch
plenty of fish with monster of the deep
but you can start cooking them up a day
before with battle chef brigade step 1
hunt down the monsters in combo heavy
battles step 2 cook them up via puzzle
based recipes two chefs compete against
each other to win a tournament and join
the battle chef brigade itself which
means two totally different campaigns to
experience you can try them both on ps4
PC and Nintendo switch on Monday xx
fingers crossed for some Animal House
DLC down the road
[Music]
speaking of fights river city rivals
showdown is all about street brawls
kunio has three days to find out who
kidnapped his girlfriend and he'll have
to beat the information out of all sorts
of street thugs this is a 25th
anniversary remake of River City ransom
with a revamped art style and multiple
new paths and endings rival showdown
dropped in Japan last year but 3ds
owners in North America can take a swing
at it on Tuesday the 21st remember when
I said you could play most of these
games in your car while gear Club
unlimited is the perfect choice for
getting really meta with it
this is the switch's first real world
driving game complete with shiny famous
cars and over 400 tracks to race them on
it wouldn't be a driving game without
online leaderboards for the best times
and local 4 player split-screen either
you can start your engine on the 21st
speaking of vehicles and other units and
stuff let's finish up with tiny metal if
you've been itching for a new advance
wars game this is definitely the next
best thing you've got infantryman land
vehicles and flying ships to command
across a 20-hour campaign between hero
units battle tactics and special attacks
you'll have quite a lot of strategies to
devise across the tile baseboards tiny
metal marches onto ps4 PC and Nintendo
switch on the 21st and those are some of
the hottest games we'll be playing this
week as always remember that release
dates are based on retailer listings and
are subject to change thanks for
watching guys and I'll be back with
another batch of new releases next
Sunday